uh they're now blaming rap music and
then of course the classic video games
as well as coveted lockdowns for the
shooting in texas anything but guns
let's jump right into the first clip
ronnie jackson uh trump's former doctor
the guy who said trump trump63 and
weighs 239
uh he said listen they're focusing on
guns but we've got rap music and video
games to contend with our prayers and
our thoughts are with the families there
it's just it's unbelievable it's just a
unbelievable evil and i just i don't
know how someone could actually do
something like this i think you know
there's going to be all kinds of
discussions coming up unfortunately you
know in in the media regarding uh second
amendment and regarding uh
the the other issues
around guns in in this country but i
think we really need to ask the question
as well how could something like this
happen how could somebody do something
so evil i mean what kind of person what
kind of animal can do this and i think
you know we i i grew up in a small town
in west texas not too much uh not not
too much smaller than the than uvaldi
and i could never imagine something like
this happening when i grew up but when i
grew up things were different you know
there was a focus on family and
community and church and i think that
you know we we knew each other and and
i'm not saying that the people in uvalde
don't know each other but i think that
that that's been that's been robbed from
us our culture has changed over the last
you know 30 or 40 years and and and
there's been an attack on those on those
things in particular and i just think
that kids are exposed to all kinds of
horrible stuff nowadays too i look back
and i think about the you know the
horrible stuff that they hear when they
listen to rap music the video games that
they watch from a really early age with
all of this horrible violence and stuff
and i just think that you know in rap
music and violent video games now is the
united states the only country with rap
music no
is the united states the only country
where kids play violent video games no
are we the only country with this many
guns per capita yes we are
uh tucker carlson talked about the
lockdowns the lockdowns cause mental
illness and mental illness leads to
shootings and you be uh you do the math
oh so the lockdowns dramatically
increase the incidence of mental illness
among young people and in 10 days we've
seen two mass shootings by mentally ill
young people could there be a connection
now that's not finger pointing it's not
to blame fauci for yesterday's shooting
we're not that low we're not joe biden
but if people are becoming mentally ill
because they're disconnected from others
what can we do to connect them to others
and thereby reduce the incidence of
mental illness that's a so of course
this is a very very
uh
pathetic misunderstanding of what it
means
to say mental illness but we're not the
only country that dealt with covid in
fact many other countries did way more
in terms of restrictions why aren't they
having more shootings and by the way
texas did almost nothing which is where
the uvalde shooting took place
and were the only ones with the mass
shooting problems and by the way the
mass shootings didn't start during or
after covid they've been going on for a
very long time so they will not stop
they will blame anything but guns
and now i want to talk about the mental
health component